oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
écoute moi quand le top-10 de j'aime à
dire oh le demande si on ne monte pas un
goût pour avis des monstres à titus
titus à quelle affaire quelle affaire
banon morgan à beauvais ce qui arrive
aux flèches
si tu vois tu es le grand jacques
remerciements tu as tu serais bien dans
nos bras lien je n'irai pas le voir on
vous dit titus tu vas le voir ils voient
que cherchait elle est pour moi est oui
si tu veux bien me suivre en passant
devant sûr mais les fils est venu butt
joue deux situés brave tuffeau une tige
à droite on va vous êtes trop bon tu
veut l'attraper
les tripes et le prisonnier certainement
grand tu veux me l'apporté ficelé
compter sur moi grand rien qu'à qui doit
rattraper fils les certitudes
il s'agit de la petite bérénice wah wah
capture et bérénice leur fille stella
livrer au grand via ka hora mais les
mais c'est sûr que tu viens de promettre
aux grandes ya qu un pas courageux titus
tu es jolie joue en ce moment on joue
pour être en papillon non non non non
non non tu peux pas faire intervenir un
possible le vivre notre corps vous avez
devant vous le lion le plus malheureux
de l'acteur mon émoi au conseil conseil
telle joie conseil taxe dite conseil de
discipline conseil d'état et cetera et
cetera ou voilà le grand gars travaux
causent aux capteurs bérénice et que
veux la lui libre ficelé connaissez vous
une bonne tu as fait de cachette
veux-tu me grattais le crâne titus ça va
me donner le nid des douches peau douce
bois voilà hallyday la grotte potiche la
grande bâtisse est patent m
maintenant vous êtes trop minable une
cure à raison dans cette partie bel et
mr à l'abri be nice bérénice c'est tout
petit appel vient vite que se passe-t-il
qui tissent ne me pose pas de questions
il faut que tu te passe dans l'impôt
tiff et que tenant bon veut plus où ces
noirs là dedans
si tu veux voir la vie en rose il faut
coutume pas un moment dans le noir allez
petit toit c'est bien pour te faire
plaisir au plan maintenant croyant pas à
nous deux les ruelles et sur beat it is
il me voit cityville et l'issue rivière
fils il rit je n'ai pas refusé parce que
je n'ai pas pu l'attraper en grand la
gavotte fuyant incapable à maladroit
j'ai cru à tenir plus de 20 fois exact
voix a glissé dans les doigts voilà
grand yaka vous demande votre d'une
banque mais qu'est-ce qui est jeune qui
met les doigts link bab inutile j'étais
fleury d'honnêteté vis de coups de
marteau tu surpris les devient belle
fille nommée de taudis tu seras pas du
service des tours si vous tombez elles
vont entraver le gran vía cas mais
attention attention gros caca quatuor
j'ai pris sur moi moi le great là mais
c'est sûr mais cologne eu lieu mythique
où mes débuts et vous vite les multis
titus est là et transat a ranimé vous
constants têtu tu m'as sauvé la vie vous
pouvez le tir sans lui vous étiez croire
il ya qu à carouge
dis-moi dis-moi ce que tu désires et je
te fais que des bains en cause si vous
voulez bien me donner la grande pompe
hills
vous savez celle qui ne sert à rien
il demande qu'une partie sinon non non
non non vous ne revenez pas je sais où
elle est merci grand yaka merci pour un
beau cadeau fait un beau cadeau la
maison de brume humide et à toi après
c'est une autre histoire
[Applaudissements]